[Musique]
daniel desrosiers mélanger exploratoire
on retrouve à la ferme de bord du lac
les arts sur le ferme qui agit comme un
incubateur pour les agriculteurs un
débat
deux mois j'ai été court terme à la
mobilière pendant 30 ans j'ai récemment
pris une
retraite de milieux financiers ou faire
un virage puisque ma passion était
depuis des années à faire de la boulange
on travaille qu'avec des grains
ancestraux dont le petit épeautre
l'amidonnier la tutelle qui vient de la
france on a eu des semences du musée des
ressources naturelles de toulouse où le
blé effectivement il est presque
disparition
dans les derniers 50 ans 75% des espèces
de blé ont disparu parce que des
croisements de blé pour l'industrie
manufacturière à renforcir le gluten en
boulangerie et d'augmenter les
rendements au chant le boulanger utilise
la farine avec dufort gluten pour
préparer le pain rapidement procédé et
de l'eau les incohérences du terme sont
survenus
[Musique]
nos clients qui sont capables de
consommer des blés ancestraux de
fabrication artisanale où le vin sans
problème d'intolérance au gluten
non c'est pas rentable c'est une passion
si ça avait été fait qui va le faire
puis pourquoi qu'on le ferait fort on a
21 paires certifiés bio les pins se
vendent entre 7 et 9 $ et notre
production on se rend compte qu'il ya un
marché parce que notre production est à
pleine capacité
est-ce que la boulangerie desrosiers a
une capacité de l'augmentation de
surproduction oui est-ce que moi
personnellement je n'intéresse pas
nécessairement sauf que mon approche a
augmenté la production ou la
consommation de ces blés ancestraux là
c'est d'éviter des boulangers existants
des jeunes dans ma boulangerie
informations place qui savent pour
comment ça fonctionne mais un grand
grand intérêt à venir chez nous pour
qu'on puisse leur montrer comment faire
et en décembre on va commencer déco pour
la population générale qui sont
intéressés à prendre des coups sur les
neuf mon plaisir de partager pour la
garder
j'ai toujours pensé que des marques de
commerce est un frein sur l'évolution
alors augmenter la vitesse de
l'évolution pour garder le secret
[Musique]